NGOZI: Hi you tube. My name is Ngozi Okonjo-Iwela.
I'm Managing Director of the World Bank. I'm
very concerned about the impacts of the [INAUDIBLE
- NOISE] global financial crisis on developing
countries. They are being hit now in several
ways. First of all[INAUDIBLE]prices natural
resourse products, experiencing declines in
income like cotton has fallen off, you name
it so many natural resources. [INAUDIBLE]
many people, [INAUDIBLE] who used to send
money home [INAUDIBLE]are down for many governments,
experience 40% since the last [INAUDIBLE]
in remittances, this is important. And then,
in addition, Foreign Director investments
is drying up. So many investments that were
going to be made by [INAUDIBLE] $350,000,000
investments in Zambia, these are no longer
going to be made. So this means that unemployment
is going to be an issue in many of the countries.
All I'm trying to say is that we have one
integrated world and what is happening in
developed countries is also impacting the
developing ones. Therefore, when we think
of stimulous packages, we need to think not
just of the developed countries, but also
how can we help the developing of low income
countries to have a stimulous package as well.
You must remember that these countries have
also been suffering from a food crisis. So
you have financial crisis [INAUDIBLE] and
a food crisis and we need to make sure that
1 billion people who don't have enough to
eat don't suffer any futher. Now the President
of the World Bank [INAUDIBLE] has suggested
that each developed country that has a stimulous
package devotes 0.7% of it to help developing
countries to have their own stimulous so that
demand is these countries can also be improved.
I think this is a good idea. I'd love to know
what you of it. Hope to hear from some of
you. Thank you.